two animals killed at a popular tourist
spot on fossil ridge in charleston in
the red rock conservation area so park
rangers with the bureau of land
management are trying to find out who's
responsible mary jane bellissa takes us
to cowboy trail rides and shares the
owner's plea tonight
when you hear innocent animals being
shot you know it i think you'd have to
be a sick individual for it to not
bother you a little bit michael flood
ranch manager of cowboy trail rides is
worried about the rest of his animals
after a series of attacks on his horses
and mules the first incident started
four weeks ago when he suspected someone
unlocked the gate and let all the horses
out after that we had a three-year-old
horse in really good health
that we had rode the day before been
with he ended up dead in the pin the
next morning we can't confirm that he
was shot blood says he's never
experienced anything like this during
his 26 years of operation
the next weekend we had
more horses turned out
and
that was a little strange and this last
saturday we had one of our mules in the
pen and she was shot in the head and
killed and we confirmed that she was
shot in the head cowboy trail rides is
on blm land blm rangers will be
investigating this case along with
assistance from the las vegas metro
police department in the meantime mike
floyd is asking the community for help
if they have any information leading to
the guy or you know have heard somebody
saying you know something about cowboy
trail rides and not liking horses we'd
love to have information given to the
rangers or the blm or anyone that you
know is willing to help we would love
all the help we can get reporting in red
rock mary jane balleza live local now
so you're asked to call metro crime
stoppers tip line that number is
702-385-5555
if you have any information and remember
that you can remain anonymous